carl anthony towns has it against
thought maker drives it
and dumps with one tenth of a second to
play
in the third
[Music]
almost 60 from the floor over the past
five games and
he's had some really excellent games
how about that out of delos looked like
he was trying to get a foul call
he's able to draw fouls while tripling
the basketball and keep his hand down
deangelo russell there dribbling with
his right hand he's able to
create the contact cross over back to
his strong hand
and then get the layup to go that was
something
couldn't handle the pass wolf looking to
get it up the floor
quickly russell behind the back beasley
for the stuff again jj
throws it up hilo he drops it off for a
really beastly
and hammers at home it's a nice
because they can shoot the three ball
the mid-range jumper and then play with
their back to the basket
covington talks it away towns gonna take
the mammoth
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
beasley forces the turnover there
gets out in transition just like he
wants to do
except the two run by the wolves derozan
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
take off i mean they're they're not even
running really
a break and here comes something called
anthony towns
oh it's picked off by d'angelo russell
here's beasley oh he's got the field
goal and the fallout jay crowder this
thing just went from bad
to worse 12 just a couple minutes ago
tough pass there by
jimmy butler puts the heat
in a disadvantage carl anthony counts
[Applause]
[Music]
the deck and gets pulled by o'neal and
one
he's got to find a way to hook something
so he hunts this one
pump fake drive race o'neill
tries to wrap carl there's all kinds of
contacts here and carl just
getting his way through
[Music]
crowd on his feet here at chesapeake
[Applause]
arena
but here is towns what a move here mike
127 126. he don't have any timeouts
[Music]
watch this
[Music]
that's tremendous defense by minnesota
three players on the ball
straight straight up and down too eric i
mean typically
this many guys someone's gonna what up
it's your boy adam lefkow did you like
that content i know you like that
content hit subscribe
for more of it from bleach report